Speaker 1: We have another Supreme Court decision
from the current Supreme Court, which is by any
stretch of the imagination, an activist Supreme
Court. It's a Supreme Court whose interpretation
of freedom of religion is the freedom to impose
religion. And it just so happens it's always some
form of Christianity or some some some version of
someone's belief about what Christianity is unto
others. What is the decision that I'm talking
about? The Supreme Court is backing a coach
who prays on the field after games. This is a
story we talked about when it happened and when it
became an issue and when the prayer at the school
became an issue. And it has now found its way,
all the way up to the Supreme Court. And we now
have a decision, the Associated Press reports.
The Supreme Court said Monday yesterday a high
school football coach who knelt and prayed on
the field after games was protected by the
Constitution, a decision that opponents said would
open the door to, quote, much more coercive prayer
in public schools. Absolutely. And we will talk
about that. The court ruled 6 to 3 for the coach
with the conservative justices in the majority,
the liberals in the dissent. This was the latest
in a line of rulings for religious plaintiffs.
Listen. When you put a right, it's sometimes
we just miss the forest for the trees or
we don't see what's right in front of us or
whatever metaphor, analogy you want to use.
We have one of the most right wing
Christians Supreme Courts in a long time,
and they are ruling for the imposition
of Christianity. That's I mean,
that that's the bottom line. The case forced
the justices to wrestle with how to balance
the religious and free speech rights of teachers
and coaches with the right of students not to feel
pressured into participating in religious
practices. The liberal justices in the minority
said there was evidence that Bremerton High School
coach Joseph Kennedy's prayers at the 50 yard line
had a coercive effect on students and allowed him
to incorporate his personal religious beliefs into
a school event that the coaches Christian. After
the games, he would lead prayer at the 50 yard
line. Now the liberal justices said there's a
coercive aspect to it on students. There's a
power dynamic. Of course, dissenting Justice Sonia
Sotomayor wrote that the decision sets us further
down a perilous path in forcing states to entangle
themselves with religion. Why states? Well,
because this is a public school. It is a state run
school, and therefore it is, in a sense, a state
government. When you look at an image of what
the prayer looked like, you can see that this
is an establishment of the prayer. This is not
I mean, for people who are watching, you've got
the coach and the prayer circle of players around
him and then media around that taking pictures.
You're telling me there's no coercive effect for
the player who would rather be outside of the
circle? The one the two players who say, yeah,
I'm opting out of this. You're saying there is
no reasonable feeling if you're one of the players
that, well, I'm not being forced, but I'm sort of
stigmatizing myself if I say I'm going to opt
out of this dog and pony show. Of course not. And
that's the point that Sonia Sotomayor was making.
On the other hand, back to the Associated Press
article, the justices in the majority emphasized
the coach's prayers came after the games were over
and at a time when he was no longer responsible
for students and was free to do other things.
Come on, guys. Come on. This. So
because the game ends now. There's no
more coercive impact. There's no more power
dynamic. Well, the game's technically over.
So now what the coach is doing with the vast
majority of the players has no impact on me.
No. The coach and his attorneys at First
Liberty Institute, a Christian legal group,
were among those cheering the decision.
Kennedy said his first reaction was pure joy.
Judge Neil Gorsuch, writing for the majority,
declared the Constitution and the best of
our traditions, counsel, mutual respect and
tolerance, not censorship and suppression for
religious and non-religious views alike. But
when this is what the coach is establishing,
the coach is very clearly setting religious views
above non-religious views. So Gorsuch also noted
the coach prayed during a period where school
employees were free to speak with a friend, call
for a reservation at a restaurant, check email or
attend to other personal matters while students
were otherwise occupied. This is yet another.
This is the latest completely improper decision
from its a right wing Christian court deciding for
right wing Christianity. Now do any of us believe
that if this was the situation but the coach
were Muslim or the coach were a Satanist
or whatever the case may be that the entire
religious community would see this the exact
same way. I mean, would even the very Christians
applauding this decision see it the same way they
would? Of course not. They would be saying it's
this is pushing Muslim beliefs. This is pushing
satanic beliefs on the students. The students
are the students. They they're at a power
disadvantage. This is completely improper.
The coach is in a position of authority.
The coach controls who gets to play. The coach
controls who makes the team. The following year,
the players will feel pressured to engage in the
prayer so as not to anger the coach. It's implicit
that the coach decides who makes the cut,
who gets to play. And so when the coach says,
Join me in prayer, but it's just optional, you can
go and check your email if you want or walk away.
The pressure is there. And Sonia Sotomayor is 100%
correct that it is coercive. All he has to do is
say, we're going to pray now. And because of the
dynamic, it's the same as if it was in a science
classroom. Okay. If in a science classroom, the
biology teacher says, we're going to pray now.
Oh, but by the way, I mean, listen, it's just
optional. I'm going to pray and most of us are
going to pray, but you don't have to. The power
imbalance is the implied pressure. The coaches
have more power than the athletes. The teachers
have more power than the students. This is the
way it is. And unfortunately, this is not going
to be the final decision, the last decision
that goes this way with this Supreme Court. You
disagree with me, let me know. We have a headline
that is scaring many in our audience. 1 million
voters have switched to the Republican Party.
Does this spell disaster for the upcoming
2022 midterms? Well, let's think about it.
These are the most important midterms in a long
time. Now, if you've been watching this show
for a while, you know, I am not hyperbolic with
the importance of any particular election. I've
said this before. In 2012, when Mitt Romney
was challenging Barack Obama's reelection,
I supported Barack Obama. I didn't support Mitt
Romney. I believed Obama was the better choice.
But there was no feeling, at least for me,
that the future of the country was riding on
that. Yeah, I agreed more with Obama than Romney.
Romney would have lowered taxes for the rich and
would have done other things I don't agree with
in his social views. As a conservative Mormon or
not my views. But it was not the most important
election of our time of the 2014 midterm. It was
not the most important election of our
time, and I didn't call it that at the time.
I can't remember a more important midterm
than the 2022 midterm. And so when we now
see these headlines, more than 1 million
voters switched to the Republican Party
in a warning for Democrats, it is a concerning
and disturbing headline. Now, yesterday, we
talked about on the one hand, it seems as though
Democrats actually have some pretty reasonable
they have a reasonable case to make with two
issues the overturning of Roe v Wade and the
unwillingness and disinterest from Republicans in
acting on gun safety legislation. Democrats have
some powerful things to run on. If voters still
care about them in four and a half months, that's
good for Democrats. On the other hand, what about
this? A political shift is beginning to take hold,
writes the Associated Press. Tens of thousands
of suburban swing voters who helped fuel the
Democratic Party's gains are becoming Republicans.
More than a million voters across 43 states
have switched to the Republican Party over the
last year, according to data analyzed by the AP.
The previously unreported number reflects
a phenomenon playing out in virtually every
region of the country Democratic and Republican
states, along with cities and small towns. In the
period since Joe Biden replaced Trump. Nowhere
is the shift more pronounced and dangerous for
Democrats than in the suburbs where well-educated
swing voters who turned against Trump's Republican
Party in recent years are swinging back.
Swinging back. Far more people are switching
to the Republican Party in counties from
Denver to Atlanta, Pittsburgh and Cleveland.
Republicans also gaining ground in. Medium
sized cities such as Harrisburg, Pennsylvania.
Raleigh, North Carolina. Augusta, Georgia. And
Des Moines, Iowa. Now, what does this mean? Well,
on the one hand, we have to understand that
the United States is a country plagued by
ignorance. The country is plagued by ignorance.
So you see very clear differences. Democrats,
not nearly liberal or left wing enough for me,
but at least connected to reality on fundamental
issues of science, of reality to some degree
about economic justice. And it's not a perfect
party. Of course, I have so many complaints
about the Democratic Party, but at least
connected to reality. On the Republican side,
particularly as Trumpism has has taken over,
there has been this plague of ignorance which is
not only present, it's celebrated. And you'll see
some clips later in the show that remind us
of this. And it is not a shock in that sense
that we are seeing voters to some degree fall
for Joe Biden. Did high gas prices, Joe Biden
did inflation. Joe Biden is responsible for what's
happening in Ukraine or whatever the case may be.
And that they would say, well, I guess I'll
abandon the Democratic Party and vote for
Republicans. It doesn't make any sense when we
think about it. It seems completely backwards.
But that's not a shock. But there's a couple of
caveats with this voter registration shift that
I think are important to keep in mind. One is
there are many libertarians that are becoming
Republicans. And so there's a difference
between a Democrat becoming a Republican
and a libertarian becoming a Republican.
Libertarians in the United States tend to vote
with the Republican Party anyway. The American
libertarian movement is pretty right wing.
And so if you take this would sort of be like,
I'm an independent voter, I'm unregistered,
I'm not a Democrat or a Republican. If I were
to announce to you I am now becoming a Democrat,
if a million people like me said I am now a
Democrat, does it really change anything about
the outcome of elections? Because I mostly vote
for Democrats anyway. I just don't care about
the Democratic Party. It's not if I'm going
to be a member of something, I want to do that
enthusiastically. I have no enthusiasm for the
Democratic Party as a party, so I'm just an
independent and I vote for Democrats. 4 million
people like me become Democrats doesn't really
make a difference. And so of those million, I
don't have the exact numbers, but a bunch of
them are libertarians who are mostly right wing
and vote for Republicans or don't vote at all
becoming Republicans. And it doesn't necessarily
mean that the balance is going to shift. The other
caveat is that this study about the million voters
becoming Republicans. This was before the gun
rights discussion that has surfaced after a number
of school shootings and mass shootings. And this
is before the Supreme Court overturned Roe v Wade.
And so while we can believe the data that the data
this is good data, that the data is real. There's
the libertarian element that I mentioned, which is
a caveat. And there's also we don't know yet what
the full effect of Roe v Wade being overturned
and the anger about Republican unwillingness to
deal with with gun safety, that is not yet part
of the polling. So is it a good sign for 22? No,
it's not a good sign, but it doesn't have to be
the disastrous sign that some are making it out to
be. That's my interpretation. Let me know yours.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman. We're
going to take a quick break and be back right
after this. We have seen a very interesting turn
of events over the last few days, this lawyer,
John Eastman. He's the guy who wrote the memo
to Donald Trump saying here is how Mike Pence
could overturn the election. There is a question
as to whether Eastman really believed that that
was a viable way to overturn the election or
knew it would be against the law. And this has
become a very central issue in the January 6th
committee. Eastman has now appeared on Tucker
Carlson saying that the FBI seized his phone last
week. There is video of the FBI seizing his phone
last week. And to many of us, this doesn't come as
a surprise because supposedly this other attorney,
Hirschmann, testified. The other attorney, Eric
Hirschmann, testified that he told Eastman,
you need a criminal defense attorney for what
you've done here. So we're going to go through
all of it. But for starters, here is Tucker
Carlson, very, very angry, showing the video
of Eastman having his phone seized by the FBI.
Speaker 2: Now, critically and illegally,
they seized his phone before they presented
him with a warrant. And it's on tape. Watch.
Speaker 3: So what turns out for
me when I see much more clearly.
Speaker 4: I'd like to see.
I'd like to see the morning.
I'd like to see the warrant. I'd like to see.
Unidentified: The warrant before. Take my
property.
Speaker 4:
I want you to see that they took my property
before providing me with the warrant.
Speaker 3: I'd like to read the law.
Speaker 1: Okay. Now, I have to tell you, I am.
As for due process as anyone else. If they didn't
have a warrant, I would be saying this is an
absolute travesty of justice. I spoke to a couple
of criminal defense attorneys and they said,
you know, this is really sort of a technicality.
The concern is the reason you grab the phone and
then show the warrant is he could smash the phone.
Okay. If you say you don't, here's the warrant.
Take your time to read it in a second. He grabs
the phone, throws it on the ground and crushes it
and destroys evidence. Now, would that be a crime?
Yes. But if the evidence is gone, the evidence is
gone. So criminal defense attorney attorneys told
me this is not we just show up and steal a phone.
If law enforcement shows up and steals a phone,
they have the warrant. They wanted to secure the
phone. They show the warrant. And the warrant,
of course, was for the phone and that's it.
So in I'm not a lawyer and speaking to lawyers,
they said this is this is not the travesty of
justice that Tucker Carlson is making it out
to be. So then Tucker Carlson invites Eastman,
and Eastman says that by seizing the phone,
it's also a crime because he has privileged
communications with clients on the phone.
Speaker 4: This warrant is invalid on its face.
But more importantly and and I think this is
extremely important, the authority to seize all
of my information in modern, modern smartphones.
That's access to all my private financial records.
I'm an attorney. It's access to all my privilege
communications with nearly 100 different clients
that I have currently. All this stuff. This
stuff is what we used to call a general warrant
that the British king issued to just go
rummage through somebody's belongings
to see if they could find evidence of some
crime. The very reason we have the Fourth
Amendment is to prevent that kind of abuse.
Speaker 1: It's very weird because he's the
lawyer, but he seems to misunderstand so
many things. His argument, it almost sounds
like a you can never seize the phone of a lawyer.
Lawyers use phones to communicate with clients.
If you can never sees a phone, if it has client
communications, it's almost like you can never
investigate a lawyer. I mean, this this is the way
investigations work. And of course, the handling
of the privileged information is a different
matter. But is is this guy really this dumb?
Now, any of us who have been paying attention
to this would have anticipated that this would
have happened. Here is attorney Eric Hershman,
who for the January six committee described
speaking to John Eastman and saying
what you need to do is get yourself a
criminal defense attorney for what you're doing.
Speaker 3: EASTMAN And remember why he called me
or he texted me or called me. Want to talk
with me? He said he couldn't reach others.
And he started to ask me about something dealing
with Georgia and preserving something potentially
for appeal. And. I said to him, Are you
out of your f ing mind? I said. I said,
I only want to hear two words coming out of
your mouth. For now on. Orderly transition.
No screams that I don't want to hear any other f
ing words coming out of your mouth no matter what,
other than orderly transition. Repeat
those words to me and I feel 97
eventually. You said orderly transition.
I said, Good, John. Now I'm going to give
you the best free legal advice you're ever
getting in your life. Get a great F in criminal
defense lawyer. You're going to need it.
Speaker 1: Right. So we all, of course,
have been expecting this to happen. And indeed,
now it did. Now here's the cherry on top.
Tucker Carlson, you know, just lionizing this guy
who came up with an illegal way to try to prevent
Joe Biden from becoming president. Tucker says if
you're not a Biden voter, you should regularly be
purging your phone of all of your text messages
and emails because they could be coming for you.
Speaker 4: The very reason we have the Fourth
Amendment is to prevent that kind of abuse.
And yet that's what they're doing here.
Speaker 2: And it's just another reminder to
anyone who didn't vote for Joe Biden to raise your
texts and emails every single day. And that is the
sincere piece of advice I hope everyone follows,
but they haven't charged with a crime. They've
given you no evidence that they're going to charge
you with a crime, but they treat you like a drug
kingpin or a rapist and seize your phone.
Speaker 1: Is this legal?
Speaker 4: I don't think so.
Speaker 1: And it's it it appears
that it is actually illegal. So there's
Tucker Carlson recommending clear your phone
of all texts and emails every day. If you didn't
vote for Joe Biden, these people live in a fantasy
world. But it is a dangerous fantasy world where
their delusions have real world impact. We expect
that at some point the spin was going to be under
fire legally and it appears that he now is. We
will follow it. I want to follow up on yesterday's
discussion about will they imprison women who seek
abortions? And will they imprison or attempt to
imprison doctors who perform abortions? Abortion
has become a criminal act in the state of
South Dakota. South Dakota. The governor
of South Dakota is Kristi Noem. Kristi Noem is a
big Trump tool, a big Trump suck up brown noser.
And I want to focus in on this question of going
after abortion doctors. She did a number of
interviews on Sunday, pieces of which we looked at
yesterday. But I want to focus in on this issue of
imprisoning doctors now in multiple interviews,
Kristi Noem went out of her way to say, we're
not going to prosecute women when it comes to
abortion. Although she left the possibility open
if women went to a different state where abortion
is legal and then come back to South Dakota. That
was a little scary yesterday, but she is making
clear there seems to be a significant appetite
in South Dakota to go after legally the doctors
performing abortions. Let's take a look at this
first clip from Face the Nation on Sunday.
Speaker 5: America has the worst maternal
mortality rate of any developed country. What
specifically are you doing for these women who
not just when they have the baby, but during
their pregnancy? Are you giving them paid
leave? Are you giving them more health care
rights in your state? Are you giving them
more state funding? What exactly are you
doing to keep them alive during a pregnancy?
You know, I think that will be a lot of the debate
that will go on now in every different state now
that the Supreme Court has made this decision.
Speaker 1: The but she's not asking about
the debate. She's asking, what
are you doing in South Dakota?
Speaker 5: Or to make these decisions really goes
to each individual state. We've already talked
about that in South Dakota. What's the state's
role in this and what can we do to help these
individuals that are in these situations, get them
the health care that they need to to help their
baby be born healthy and help them be parents or
help them choose a loving family to raise that.
Speaker 1: So a non-answer. Okay.
Speaker 5: So you're still figuring out
the results. Okay. Well, and this trigger law was
put into place years ago, and it was to go into it
into law as soon as the Supreme Court made a
decision, such as it did. So that's the debate
and discussion that we're having. But I think
what's incredible and what's going on is that
the people will decide, you know,
elected officials at the state level
is who they'll be talking to, to decide what
their state's laws look like. South Dakota's
obviously, you know, under our past several years
and have stood for life and defending life. And
I think we'll continue to have those debates
on how we can support these mothers and what
it means to really make sure that we're not
prosecuting mothers ever in a situation like
this when it comes to abortion, that
it will always be focused towards
those doctors who knowingly break the
law to perform abortions in our state.
Speaker 1: The criminal charges will
be focused on the doctors, the doctors.
She then appeared on This Week and again she
said if doctors knowingly break the law, they
should indeed be prosecuted. Let's take a look.
Speaker 3: And what about medication, abortions,
the so-called abortion pill? How will
you know if women receive those in the
mail and should those women be prosecuted?
Speaker 5: I don't believe women should ever
be prosecuted. I don't believe the mothers
in this situation to ever be prosecuted as
doctors who knowingly violate the law.
They should be prosecuted, definitely.
And we've been told this. Okay. You're saying the
pills. Okay. Again, Martha, you're interrupting,
but I am answering your question. I don't
believe that that telemedicine abortions are
safe for individuals, for women to conduct at
home. Many times they're doing it unsupervised.
It's a medical procedure. And so I do believe that
there should be a physician supervision in place
when that is being conducted by any individual.
Speaker 1: All right. So they're going to go
after the doctors and they do seem to sort of be
cohering around this talking point. Remember that
early in Trumpism, they weren't totally clear
on do you punish the women? Because there was
this time Trump was asked about, do you
punish the women? And Trump said, yes.
Speaker 3: Do you believe in punishment for
abortion? Yes or no as a principle? The answer is
that it has to be some form of punishment
for the woman. Yeah, there has to be some
form. 10 seconds, ten years. I don't know.
Speaker 1: There you go. And of course,
afterwards, Trump was told, no, no, no, no.
That's the wrong talking point. We don't say
that. We say punish the doctors. And by the next
day, Trump was saying, no, no, no. I didn't mean
I didn't mean punish the women. I didn't
mean that. I mean punish the doctors. Now,
two states so far, Minnesota and Massachusetts,
have seen their governors sign orders protecting
providers who perform abortions for out-of-state
residents. And that's one aspect of this.
The governors of Minnesota and Massachusetts have
implemented legal protections for reproductive
health care providers who serve out-of-state
out-of-state residents who come to their state
seeking such care. That's one aspect of this. But
this is sort of a different question, which is
what about circumstances where you have in-state?
Everything is in-state. What is it that is going
to be the goal of these extreme right wing states?
So this is increasingly looking very much like,
you know, a margaret. Margaret Atwood book. Quite
frankly, that's what it is looking like. And
it is scary stuff that we are going to continue
tracking, but it is not looking particularly good.
Hey, this is wild. This crazy Trumpist
Republican candidate, Carrie Lake.
She lost it when Fox News's Brett Beyer confronted
her about her hypocrisy on drag queens. Now,
in case you don't know about drag queens, drag
queens are typically we're talking about male
performers who use what's called drag clothing and
makeup to imitate and sometimes even exaggerate
female gender signifiers. But it's entertainment
purposes. Drag queens are not trans people. You
might have trans drag queens, but when we
talk about drag queens, we're talking about
sort of like a performance thing. We're not
talking about transgender people. Okay, fine.
So Carrie Lake has been viciously going after drag
queens and people who enjoy drag queens and all
these different things. And it turns out that a
drag queen came out and said, I've performed for
Carrie Lake. Carrie Lake as hired drag queens to
perform multiple times. She's a hypocrite. Okay.
So she goes on Fox News. Bret Beyer confronts
her. She didn't expect to be confronted about
this on Fox News. And she flips out.
Speaker 4: Says Arizona GOP candidate
who criticized drag queens was once a fan,
according to a drag queen. This is the, quote,
Arizona GOP gubernatorial way.
Speaker 1: It's obviously
so stupid what's going on. But she
is a hypocrite and good for Brett
Beyer for asking her about it.
Speaker 4: And to Carrie Lake,
who has attacked drag queens as dangerous to
children, attended the shows of drag queen Richard
Stephens for more than 20 years and once hired
him to perform at her home in care to address.
Speaker 5: I do care. I actually do care
to address that. And I'm really shocked.
I'm actually appalled.
Speaker 1: That.
Speaker 5: Fox News would take defamatory
story like that. And we are pursuing legal
action against this drag queen.
Speaker 1: Sue the drag queen.
Speaker 5: I'm appalled that you would
bring that up when you have not talked
about our stolen election. You failed.
Speaker 4: Just spent three questions,
just like talking about this issue. Ask you
a number of questions about it. I played
the Arizona. This is the first and let's
address let's address this story that's in
The Washington Post. Every candidate takes tough
stories. I'm asking you to to it. You'd like to.
Speaker 5: I'm happy to address it, but
I'm really disappointed in Fox. I thought
you were a little better than CNN.
Speaker 1: I'm really disappointed.
Speaker 5: This is a person who I covered
for decades, for decades, 20 years,
and he's never been in my home. He says he's been
in my home for a drag show. That's ludicrous. He's
never been in my home. He's lied. We tried to
serve him defamation papers and he's so shady
that we can't even track him down because
he's not even welcome at the place. What?
Speaker 4: To work? I'm sorry, but
this is the last question being asked.
What about these pictures of you with him?
Speaker 3: Isn't that the best? What about the.
Speaker 1: Pictures where you're together?
Speaker 4: Richard Stephens. Randy, what about
this? The post I perform for Carrie's birthday.
I performed in her home, perform for her at some
of the seediest bars in Phenix. I don't want to
ask these questions. I asked you to address them.
Speaker 5: I actually think I think you do
want to ask him, but you don't want to ask
about 2000 mules, right?
Speaker 1: I think Dinesh
D'Souza film, too. That's the real issue.
Speaker 5: Guys do want to ask about this. This
is absolutely ludicrous. And I'm talking about
drag shows in schools. This is what triggered
this man. Somebody who goes to a drag show with
female impersonators is one thing. We don't want
our tax money going into drag shows at school.
Speaker 4: Okay. I understand what you're
saying. You last there, but you're saying his
allegations are wrong, is what you're saying?
Speaker 5: Yes, I am.
Speaker 1: And I'm despite the pictures,
the allegations are completely untrue. Unhinged,
unhinged. And this is what it has come down to,
folks. These people are out of their minds and
they might win in November. If we don't get out
and vote, we'll have these clips on our Instagram.
Find us on Instagram at The David Pakman Show.
It is great to have back on the program. A
Zarian, who's a cognitive neuroscientist,
blogger for Psychology Today and whose new book is
The Romance of Reality How the Universe Organizes
Itself to Create Life, Consciousness and Cosmic
Complexity. Bobby, great to speaking to you again.
Speaker 6: Thanks for having me back, David.
Speaker 1: So, I mean, the book is
fascinating because it starts with these are just
big topics, right? How what what are the origins
of life? What is what is consciousness? What
is sort of our place? How do we understand our
ability to perceive and understand? But it also
has very much real world kind of day to day nitty
gritty implications about how we solve individual
problems, political questions, how people relate
to each other, how we understand what is real
and what is not real and kind of epistemology.
Can you talk just like generally what what was the
main point you wanted to get across in the book?
Speaker 6: So yeah, there are a lot of points
that you mentioned, but the general idea
is that. So it's, I guess to contrast it
to the old paradigm. The old paradigm,
the kind of reigning scientific worldview was
known as the reductionist paradigm. And it
basically says that life is something of a cosmic
accident and that life is transient and has no
larger cosmic significance. But the story that's
emerging from complexity science is challenging,
that basically says that the universe isn't
getting increasingly disordered as once thought,
it's getting more and more complex. And life
is a part of that complex ification process.
And once life emerges, it becomes the driver of
that process. So we're not an accident. We are
a natural manifestation of the laws of physics
and the evolutionary dynamics that emerge from
those laws. And this means that life has
something like a purpose in the universe,
and that's to see that life continues to
persist and spread throughout the cosmos.
Speaker 1: What's fascinating about that, to
put a pause there, is if people listen to 90%
but not 100% of what you're saying, they
might misunderstand what you're saying
as meaning either one, that there is purpose in
the way that some attribute to religion or God,
which is not what you're saying here. You're
saying that the purpose of life is is to persist.
Life wants to continue so so to speak. And number
two, if people listen to 90%, but not 100% of what
you're saying, they might think you're saying that
the preexisting ideas, for example, about entropy
are being contradicted by what you're saying,
but you're not really you're sort of expanding
on that in a sense, if I understand correctly.
Speaker 6: Yes. So to address those two points,
let's start with the entropy point first. There's
a lot of confusion about what the second law
of thermodynamics means. Yes. And there's a
statistical interpretation of that law that
basically says that ordered systems will naturally
move toward a more disordered state, and that
that's true for closed systems. So closed systems
are systems that aren't open to energy coming in
from an outside source. So the planet Earth is an
open system, and that is because we have a star,
we have our sun that is radiating all of this
energy down on the planet. And those energy flows
basically organize life. And we so energy flowing
through a simple chemical system will organize it.
And that is the mechanism that creates life on
a planet. So the idea basically is that life can
continue to persist against this tendency towards
disorder as long as it can continue to extract
energy from the environment because the energy is
used to sustain itself. But in using that energy,
it uses up ordered energy and it dissipates that
energy as heat, and that creates entropy too.
So complexity can grow and grow and grow
if life can spread and find more energy.
And the second law of thermodynamics really just
says that there's an energetic cost to creating
order, that you have to use some of this available
energy and basically turn that energy into entropy
so it doesn't violate the second law unless
you think the second law applies to the whole
universe and says that the universe is growing
increasingly disordered. This challenges that and
says we need to understand that entropy is this
complex term. It takes on a number of forms and
that life doesn't have to be transient.
If we can solve our problems and continue
to extract energy, then we can persist.
Speaker 1: The religious purpose that is
often debated by Christian apologists and others.
You're talking about purpose in a different way,
and it makes intuitive sense if you think about,
for example, evolution, right? And the idea well,
when we when we talk about purpose, you could
say the purpose here is evolution is fueling
more fit species so that they can continue to live
so that life persists. As you're talking about,
we don't have to talk about purpose
ideologically necessarily or as a
designed thing and still acknowledge that
maybe purpose could be an appropriate word
in terms of life wanting to preserve and continue.
Speaker 6: Yes. So there was a big movement to
kind of get purpose. Out of biology in the 20th
century. Right. But where understanding that
purpose or agency is really the defining
characteristic of life. So if you compare
life to an inanimate object, like a rock or a
chair, those things don't do anything interesting.
And if they move, if Iraq, you know, tumbles down
a hill, it's because of the force of gravity. Or
if you see Iraq moving on the street, it's
being pushed by a gust of wind. But life
moves according to survival goals. So it
has agency. And this agency is basically
a product of the information stored in
living systems, which are adaptive systems.
So it's really helpful to talk about purpose.
But if you zoom out and you look at the universe
and you understand that life isn't any sort of
magical, it doesn't have some sort of magical
ingredient propelling it. Then you see that the
inanimate matter in the universe is waking up
in the form of life. And so you don't see it so
much as just life trying to persist. You see it
as the universe sort of waking up through
life and being able to experience itself.
So there are some big what I would call
spiritual implications of this theory,
but it is an entirely mechanistic, naturalistic
picture because we can understand these
processes that generate complexity. We
can formalize them with mathematics. So
there's no magic in this framework. However, I
will say it is still really mysterious why the
universe is so fine tuned to give rise to life.
And if you believe the argument in this book,
it doesn't just allow life. It necessitates
life and basically ensures that life will
continue to adapt and spread.
Speaker 1: So along those lines,
when we look at societies and the way that
human society is organized, we can find lots of
relatively persistent. You know, I'm talking
here about hundreds of years, which is still a
relatively small amount of time. But but in modern
society, we see lots of mechanisms that seem like
they would run counter to that. Right. World
Wars, for example, the seeking and obtaining
of nuclear weapons, which, you know, it's hard to
argue that nuclear weapons in some longterm way
will preserve life. They seem only only able to
potentially destroyed or at best do nothing at all
conflict. So we what is the role at the sort of
more medium term society level of some of these
systems that seem to run very contrary to to life?
Speaker 6: So there's a principle in the book that
I call Popper's principle, named after the
philosopher of science, Karl Popper. And it
basically says that problems create progress. So
you mentioned World War Two, and it was a terrible
time. A lot of bad things happened, but that same
time period produced the computer and information
technology, and the computer was kind of a need
to do a couple of things. People have seen a movie
about Alan Turing where the computer was used to
crack Enigma, the Nazi code. Yep. And the computer
was also used to try to create nuclear weapons by
von Neumann and others. So you do get this kind
of paradoxical thing where you have technology
that has terrible uses and really good uses.
So it does seem a little bit contradictory,
but not when you realize that it's the problems
that we face that pushes us to find solutions
and pushes us in the direction of progress. Mass
extinctions. Basically, if you look at the
trend as far as like biological complexity
and diversity, after every mass extinction, the
biosphere went to new levels of complexity and
diversity. So it's like life adapts and evolves
and evolves because it has challenges. So
this will lead people to kind of question this
idea of progress because they see all these things
going on, these mounting existential challenges
like climate change and the threat of nuclear war,
rising income inequality. But it is
precisely those challenges that push us to
find solutions that ultimately lead to progress.
Speaker 1: Now, that doesn't mean we ignore the
like. So for example, someone might hear that
and say. Hey, listen, based on what Bobby said,
we just shouldn't worry about climate
change, because no matter even if it is
as destructive as the worst hypotheses say it is,
eventually life will persist and things will just
kind of like reorder themselves and everything
will be okay. But it sounds like what you're
saying is these are opportunities for humans
to do things and to figure out solutions.
Speaker 6: Yes. So that thing that you
said earlier would be like the the worst way to
interpret this. Yes. We can't the process doesn't
happen on its own. And it goes back to the point
that we're part of this process. Yes. So we need
to try our very best to overcome these solutions.
If not, we will be the errors that get corrected
by natural selection and the people who come after
us or the, you know, species or civilization that
comes after us will do something different.
Hopefully they'll learn from our mistakes.
But yeah, it's this process of continually
learning from failure. Right. And yeah, we. We
have to do everything in our power to overcome
these existential challenges. And one thing that
this theory kind of shows about society is that
societies work in a very similar way as organism
organisms, biological organisms. So you are an
organism, and you usually think about that as
being one single thing. But you're a collective of
cells, right? At working together in an integrated
fashion. Your brain is a collection of 80 billion
neurons, all connected by 10,000 connections each.
And the output of that collective computation is
your intelligent behavior and your productivity.
So you can look at a society as being a social
organism, and you can even look at the network
of humans that spans the planet as forming
something like a global brain because of the
Internet and social media, and now blockchain
systems connecting us in a very similar way.
And if we want to overcome our existential
challenges, we have to use the full computational
power of the global brain. And this gives us
some principles for how to optimize our social,
political and economic systems.
Speaker 1: So on that note,
in the limited time we have left all of this, if
we go down to the kind of like the nitty gritty
level. What are the immediate things that in
human society could be done, as you see it,
to better orient ourselves towards this future?
And this could be regulating social media,
passing some laws about carbon. I mean, like if we
just were to say what what are the bullet points
of things that could be done by governments
and organizations at this point to better
serve our future? Is there a sort of short list?
Speaker 6: Yes. There's a long list and a short
list. So everything that, you know, people are
fighting for right now, those are, you know,
worthy things that we should be tackling. But
there are some more basic principles that come
from complexity science, which just tells us
how to get the maximum amount of computational
power out of a system. So computational power
is a function of how complex a system is.
A system is more complex if there are more
components and there are more connections
between those components. And you also want
a variety of different types of components.
So we want to be connected in a way similar to how
neurons are connected in the brain. So any nation
that cuts their people off from the Internet
is stopping that free flow of information. And
the free the free flow of information allows for
greater social awareness and knowledge exchange.
So, you know, countries like North
Korea, Russia, China that are doing that,
that's not intrinsically good for a complex
adaptive system in the long run. The other
thing I mentioned was the need for diversity
among components. So the human body has over 200
cell types because they're doing a division
of labor, a society of all doctors or society
of all engineers or musicians wouldn't do well.
So we need specialization because it allows for
a division of labor and we so we need diversity
and not just cultural diversity, but a diversity
of ideas. So any system, any nation that doesn't
allow for criticism of the current system,
that's also intrinsically bad because you
want new ideas that challenge the status quo.
That's sort of how progress happens to the last
thing that I would say is income inequality. So
we're seeing levels of income inequality higher
than we've ever seen before, and that means
all of the resources are concentrated in these
small pockets. So that would be so if society is
a social organism that would be like all of the
resources, like the blood, the nutrients, all in
certain areas and not systemically flowing right
to all the appendages. And if that is the case,
then ultimately that super organism will
die because those parts will fester and then
affect the rest of the body. So we want to have
a way to kind of redistribute these resources.
I don't think like a communist model or like a
socialist model is necessarily the best way to
do that because you don't want like a government
with all this power, like calling the shots,
you want some sort of natural way to do that.
And I think the decentralization movement made
popular by cryptocurrencies and Bitcoin is a
way to do that because Nfts will allow for a
new crowdfunding mechanism that will allow, you
know, normal people to raise money for a business
project. And then the people who are donating to
that project, like they would Kickstarter, they
actually become investors, right? So there's a lot
of creative ways, you know, and to think about how
to structure society, maybe we need some optimal
balance between socialist and capitalist policies.
Decentralization could provide, you know, new
ideas about how to find that balance. But yeah,
we need to look at how nature has optimized
systems through evolutionary processes
to kind of teach us how to best optimize society.
Speaker 1: We've been speaking with cognitive
neuroscientist and blogger Bobby Azari, and
the new book is The Romance of Reality How
the Universe Organizes Itself to Create Life
Consciousness in Cosmic Complexity. Bobby,
always a pleasure having you on.
Speaker 6: Thank you so much,
David, and congratulations on being a new father.
Speaker 1: Thank you. Radical Trumpist Republican
Congresswoman Lauren Boebert or Boebert. For those
who prefer that pronunciation, our friend Roxana,
for example, prefers Boebert, which I kind of
I kind of like it as a satirical ring to it.
I She has gone for theocracy. She is saying she's
tired of this separation of church and state junk.
She doesn't like it. Now, this is Christian
Dominionism. This is radical Christianity. This
is a full, full fledged Christian nationalism.
And that is exactly what Congresswoman
Boebert is proposing. She spoke as usual
at some kind of crazy event in Colorado,
I guess. Who even cares? It's these wild
events. And listen to what she had to say
about separation of church and state.
Speaker 5: The reason we had
so many over reaching regulations in our nation
is because the church complied. The church is
supposed to direct the government. Why government?
Speaker 1: Wait a second. Which church?
There's like a.
Speaker 5: Thousand.
Supposed to direct the church. That is not how our
Founding Fathers intended it. And I'm tired of the
separation of church and state junk that's not in
the Constitution. It was in a stinking letter. And
it means nothing like what they say it does.
Speaker 1: Oh.
Now, which church is supposed to direct
the government? Because there are major
differences between, say, Baptists and
Pentecostals and born again Christians or
evangelicals or Catholics or whatever. Never
mind. Right. Like Jews, Muslims, atheists. Okay.
This is full fledged Christian nationalism.
It's dystopian and it's dangerous. And most
importantly, it's not true. All of the framers
of the American Constitution understood
that no establishment meant no national church, no
government involvement in religion. Period. That's
it. And they now want to try for people who
say that we should go by the letter of what
the founders said. They sure want to
do a bunch of reinterpretation now,
as usual, to just fit whatever outcome they want
today. Thomas Jefferson and James Madison believed
that unless you completely separate religion
and the state, you don't really have religious
freedom. It doesn't matter whether the founders
themselves were theists or deists or Christian or
whatever the case may be. And often people
like Lauren Boebert and others will say
these were religious individuals. And so
when they talked about all of these things,
you have to sort of read between the lines that
they mean, like this is a Christian country. No,
no, no, no, no, no. They understood even for their
own religious freedom or that of anybody else's.
There is not really religious freedom unless you
separate church and state, and that means freedom
from and of religion. And she's complaining about
overreaching regulations. How is it that people
who are worried about being told you have to
separate church and state are, on the other hand,
okay with the government telling people how to
make their own medical decisions? How can that be?
How can you simultaneously say there's too much
government overreach in trying to separate church
and state and just let everybody do whatever
they want privately and leave religion out of
government? Okay. That's too oppressive. But the
government can come in and say, oh, abortion. No,
no. We're going to decide what medical procedures
or lack thereof are best for you. And we're saying
you can't go and get it. There's a huge disconnect
somewhere between their ears. And I think it's
because it's chocolate pudding that is between
their ears. That seems to be what's going on.
And flippantly, this church. And it's sort of
like if someone were to say, I'm so sick of this
due process stuff, just throw him in jail. Just
due process of Miranda. Oh, speedy trial guys.
Just throw him in prison. That's the equivalent of
what she's saying. I'm so tired of the separation
of church and state, John. Everybody talking about
this exhausting freedom of speech. Just shut them
up. Wait, wait, but hold on. It's part of the
framework on which this country. I'm so tired of
it. Just throw it out. Dystopian. And this is what
the country would become if people like Lauren
Boebert end up being in charge. All right. I don't
want to spend a ton of time on this. Many of you
emailed me about it. This is really funny. Newsmax
host Greg Kelly is calling out Rudy Giuliani and
saying, Dude, you're claiming you got attacked. It
seems like you're exaggerating. So if you haven't
followed this story, let me back it up for you.
Rudy Giuliani was at. I guess it was like a shop,
right? And someone came up to Rudy and kind
of patted him on the back and I guess said
something negative to him. Okay. They patted
him on the back. And Rudy just turned around and
looked at them before the video was out. Rudy was
claiming that he was hit. It felt like a boulder,
that it knocked him multiple steps forward. He
thought it was I mean, that it was just like this
crazy, vicious physical attack. Then the video
came out and it becomes very clear that it was
not. Some guy patted Rudy on the back and said
something negative. Okay. Rudy has doubled down
and he keeps talking about this assault. And
this is so funny. Even cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs,
right wing Newsmax and its host Greg Kelly says,
I got to be honest, Rudy. It really doesn't
look that bad. So if you're watching, you'll
actually see the video of the I think they play
the video of the supposed assault. Check this.
Speaker 3: Out. See you do it. I didn't know it
was this good. I really did. And here's his grasp.
Speaker 1: By the way,
Rudy's audio plagued by background noise.
Speaker 3: Particularly in the issue prior
to the. More. Raising money and asking, Hey, Mr.
Mayor, is somebody mowing the lawn right outside
your window? I can barely hear you. We're at a
big rally. We're at a big rally in Staten Island,
right around the corner from
where I was attacked yesterday.
We have that, actually. You were at I guess we got
going. I want to show the people what happened.
And you tell me because let me see the video, if
you don't mind. This person with the hand on your
back. I got to be honest, it doesn't look that
bad, but I understand that looks can be deceiving.
You know, that that was that was the woman who was
rubbing my back, not the guy that you're watching.
So the woman that woman gave a statement to the
police. The guy hit me so hard that she herself
almost fell.
Speaker 1: Yeah,
it's very clear that didn't happen from the video.
Speaker 3: The reverberation of it. She's a see.
Speaker 1: The entire building echoed from when
Rudy was patted on the back. It reverberated.
They were worried it was going to break glass.
Speaker 3: There's a second grade detective
that. That's the lady who helped me. All
right, go ahead. That makes sense. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Guys, when Greg Kelly from Newsmax is
saying, you know, it really doesn't seem that bad,
you might have gone a little bit too far saying
that it reverberated throughout it reverberated
throughout the building. Can you imagine? So,
okay, so that's the Rudy thing. I don't really
want to talk about it too much more, but and
of course, if if some if someone doesn't want
to be touched, they shouldn't be touched. That's
absolutely the case. Okay. So I'm not defending,
but it was like a boulder. It knocked me forward
multiple steps. The guy patted Rudy and Rudy
turned to his left. That's all that happened.
Okay. So Greg Kelly is not buying it. We have
a voicemail number. That number is 2192. David P
here is a really great question about the recent
medical drama that I talked about yesterday,
including the C-section, birth of my daughter
and the rehospitalization of
my girlfriend for a perforated
duodenum. Duodenum. People were emailing me
saying, Sorry, you're pronouncing it incorrectly.
Speaker 3: Nuclear proliferation.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I'm doing my
best with pronunciation. Anyway, here's an
interesting question about the entire thing.
Speaker 3: Hey, David. I love your girlfriend is
all right, but I have a question. I don't know
what type of health insurance you guys have run
an independent business. Correct. But how much did
all this cost? How much were you billed for? The
last time I went to the hospital, they charge me
$10,000 to go 5 minutes down the street. Yep.
Fortunately, though, I was on Medicaid at the
time, so I didn't have to pay for any of it.
Speaker 1: This is a great question. We have
not gotten any bills yet. Okay. I do plan
to open up the books like I did after my
appendectomy. You might remember my
appendectomy. It was about 40 grand,
of which I had to pay my $2,000 deductible. Okay.
So. Indeed, both. Both of us are self-employed,
and so we buy insurance from our state's
marketplace. When back during my appendectomy,
when I was in Massachusetts, I bought I had a
plan I purchased through what's called the mass
health connector. New York State has a similar
thing through which we now have our plans called
My State of Health. These are not the
best plans. Okay. So my expectation is
that we are going to owe the $2,000 deductible
for the birth and that Associated Hospital stay,
the $2,000 deductible for the rehospitalization,
for the surgery. And then because of the ambulance
call, I think that we probably have like
a man, it's probably a $500 co-pay for the
ambulance ride like these plans. These are not
cheap plans and they also cover very little.
So that's what I expect. Oh, I think our
we're going to owe somewhere between four
and $5,000 for all of this. I think the billed
amounts could could probably get to $250,000.
My understanding is that C-section, birth
and subsequent hospitalization can be
80 grand or so. And then the surgery plus like a
six day hospitalization after that in I think it's
considered subacute care. I don't really know.
That could be another that could be 100 grand
one way. I think that the sort of sticker price
on everything is going to be somewhere around
200,000, could even be a little bit higher. We
will see. And I expect we will go somewhere around
four or 5000. So I'll open the books when we get
the bills. I haven't gotten them yet. I'll keep
everybody posted. We've got a great bonus show for
you today with some horrible stories, by the way.
One positive thing is Elizabeth Warren says
Democrats are only two votes away from codifying
Roe v Wade. Is it too late? Well, we'll talk about
it. Stacks of bodies have been found dead in a
trailer on the US-Mexico border. Horrifying story.
And a study finds that cannabis users are 25% more
likely to need emergency care or hospitalization.
But the question is, is it because of their
cannabis use or is it that people more likely
to need emergency care and hospitalization
are more likely to use cannabis, which would
be a very, very different explanation. All of
those stories and more on today's bonus.
Speaker 3: Show, the bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves as.
Speaker 1: Well. I invite you to sign up at
join pacman dot com. Get instant access to
the David Pakman show bonus show.
Speaker 4: Thank your lucky stars
every day. You're not Dave Pacman.
Speaker 1: Well, it's not that bad,
Alex. Thank you very much.
Coupon code big voting 22
sign up it joined Pacman dot com.
I will see you on the bonus. Yes.